hb embêté moi je suis embêté emmanuel
parce que tu m'as pas donné le bon
numéro
vincent cassel c'est n'importe quoi je
suis tombé sur bolloré est donc là tu
t'es complètement plantée de vincent je
me le demande à quelqu'un d'autre
ouais honorer le soldat rose d'or mais
enfin il m'a fait ça vanne perpétuelle
l'aquifère chaque fois oui passe à la
maison je te fais ma spécialité je fais
les pâtes à la baule au mercy par donc
eu garrel il là c'est sûr excusez-moi
pas d'enjeu monsieur non ne vous le fais
pas chier film capte bonjour monsieur -
mademoiselle vous bougez pas je suis
filmé comme tout au monde york
mon sort excusez moi à hidalgo foutez
moi une place de stationnement bat chez
moi j'en peux plus de ces autolib au les
deux roues qu'elle soit 1 [ __ ] arrêté
car elle aussi tombée au louis hall où
je suis tombé excusez moi oh
excuse moi elle me suis tombé h et
maladroite